good morning everybody so I'm extremely
behind on vlogs as usual but today Jenna
and I got to do a little bit of
Christmas shopping and then we're gonna
go see Star Wars again I saw the other
day and I thought it was really good so
I'm excited to see it again and kind of
see all the things that I missed
Jenna is going to see it yes
Maddie's very excited Matty went to the
vet yesterday I also went to the
groomers and we also I took him shopping
he picked out a new toy
here's his new toy boy Matty do you like
it yeah and I'm now making Jenna and I
some breakfast look at its toaster what
do you think I need hoster great yeah I
still have to use it you tell me
everything about your thoughts I think
you might have actually picked it out
I'm not sure surprise me hey do you
remember that one song it goes a little
something like know peek in the
president I haven't even gotten any
presents to wrap for anybody to go you
buy me whatever you want just you know I
don't know what the problem is I was
trying to think of what my shirts inside
out let's look at you all those eggs
John oh the natural reaction I'm good it
was great star where's Scarlett I got it
doesn't even can't wait to hurt I think
I'll wear it tonight I'm hoping I can
get a leather evader jacket Hot Topic
they don't have it was really upset let
me see that
baby I thought this is an emergence of
that song was just on okay with the
radio
we met the emergency button no I thought
what they want to know right I'll look
at the wild puppy just like my wild dog
kid he just won so hard you cover born
across the thing yeah oh it's over there
what's up natural selection that's why
ours has not gone on fire yet
let me see that I get a pair of
sunglasses
how pretty oh so cute pretty my
Christmas shopping morning really great
having a great time
it's surprisingly it's not that crazy
for a little the week before Christmas
it's not it so we can change the freakin
weekend with gonna have a Jennif on a
wallet
we have $13 the information penny penny
so how do we find the person who's well
at this I don't know there is no
information and this is nothing it's a
brand new wallet we are trying to debate
if we turn it into guess what someone
probably just purchased it or do we turn
in security where I agree but the
problem is where's that how do we find
the lost wait a minute we have to go in
puzzles ooh no I'd like to show you my
nails what oh but first don't look at
don't look yet okay well yes it's red
but let me show you what I showed her
let me show you what I got in the nice
already picture and she was like what do
you know that's what I showed her that's
what I show this is way way off uh the
wine I know I just let me say it again
yeah I do very nice okay come back
Monday I could fix it I was like I'm I'm
gone can use the cookies yeah I was like
honestly I don't care look at you aren't
you oh oh wait no cage with me good I'm
hungry oh we do it for cookies oh okay
Oh buddy no I gave you a snack when I'm
at home I give you snacks it didn't you
just down diseases dinner or lunch pop
whoa
speedster yeah - yeah - Chris I want it
over when I'm hungry
what's that noise there's somebody here
who's here I'm filming every single time
you come in this out every time Matt
comes home he got a bath yesterday at
the groomers you're gonna hurt your tail
buddy honey you just made these do you
know what they are a little hard do you
know what they saw us
yeah dude dude I was about to do a haul
do you guys want to see what I got today
at Hot Topic this is what I'm wearing
tonight guys do you like it cute thank
you see life Oh show them
cute cute Matt what are you wearing this
wait actually I got another one if you
want to wear it here let's show them do
you think that would fit you are you
saying that small/medium listen I don't
need Star Wars to wear okay well I just
thought I would be nice you can very
nice and you're a very nice person
thank you appreciate it beet sauce you
like pizza huh I love people
I can't wait because he start words
again you guys are gonna like it it's
gonna be very very good
what is it your jacket it's all I could
find
it's like why this is a ball because it
was got it in Norway okay it's in
Norwegian jacket so stylish
no I'm colder so we were just here
earlier and Jenna we're back again I
know I had to wait in this line to get
in so did I
Jenna was in the store I was out here
waiting in line I told you to hurry so
you just hop over it you know with me
Louie V store know we're going to see
Star Wars again Jeff and I already saw I
know second time exciting and you guys
for size first timers first time seen
bb-8
yeah pop and Yoda Jerry okay Jen your
turn to vlog now so up here I bought the
sweater today that's really catches it
is shoot Jenna here's do didn't pick up
the chairs a coffee table there you can
there's actually a concert I don't know
like a 1 0 okay well your bill you can
get on Amazon return the chairs and when
were never Nathan it's really nice over
here
look at that may the drinks be with you
morning everyone um you might be able to
see it a baby boy back there we're going
to the vet right now he's been scooting
his little bum which could mean a few
things if you have a dog you know or so
I don't need to tell you what it is um
and second he needs a little ears
cleaned out and it's really early
I took the earliest appointment for you
so that uh I could get the rest of my
things jump today you ready to go to the
vet to the vet where are we going who's
here hungry
cute potty are you are you doing a treat
so cruel hi guys where the airport right
now the dog and I Jenna is on her way
here the struggle that I had this
morning with this little guy because I
didn't call 48 hours ahead of time to
let them know that he was coming I
called this morning
so basically was my fault the woman was
like you need to get there two and a
half hours early before your flight and
I'm like I'm not packed
I go usually an hour before my flight to
hop on the plane roll out we had to get
here very very early
I wasn't packed I don't have anything I
think I brought a computer and my dog
and since what
but I think that's all I need your Maddy
lucky you being a good boy today
possibly here's your toothbrush get you
toothbrush remaining in Pittsburgh
please place all seat backs and tray
tables and their upright and locked
position any carry-on items you may have
you been using during the plan must be
bestowed at this time so we just arrived
my mom has Maddy where's Maddy where's
Mary
oh my gosh okay
all right buddy so I've been working
really hard making Christmas cookies
here Kenneth over there Roland I don't
think I've done anything yet to be
honest with you I'm tired I just woke up
it's like 4:30
well right now it's not 2:30 but I woke
up into there that's that's a lot
wonderful Christmas was a nice Christmas
siesta all day now you look at you oh
look at you guys ahh
oh hi are you gonna play with your
friend Maddie in playing Maddie has the
sweater on and someone he gets close on
he gets really calm and just fell asleep
so that's what's happening right now so
we decided to surprise our parents with
a little getaway here in Malibu so
that's that's why we're here